okay I think we'd like to go ahead and
get started with the second panel so I'd
like to welcome everyone to this panel
titled the collected campus and one of
the like to explain something like the
rationale for this panel you know there
are all kinds of quirky and unusual
things on this campus such as the
antique clocks in university hall and
other administrative buildings that a
lot of people have told us about these
are tremendously interesting to learn
about but equally surprising to myself
and Julie were the ways in which
assemblages of things at Harvard really
came to life or could be viewed through
an entirely new lens once the term
collection was applied to them this
pertains to everything from as you'll
see in this panel the buildings on
campus to the landscaped spaces on
campus to to the portraits on campus so
in that spirit I like to introduce our
three speakers today I like to introduce
them all at once and then asked them to
come to the podium one after the other
and I'll introduce them in reverse order
of presentation so the last speaker of
the panel I'll introduce first he is
Steven quoit who has since 2002 been the
official portraitist to the Harvard
foundations portrait project and that
means he's among other things he's
painted 17 portraits in and around
campus everyone from the Harvard 17th
century Native American alumnus Caleb to
president drew Faust he's currently
painting the portrait of Richard T
greener harvard's first african-american
alumnus in nineteen eighteen seventy our
second speaker for the panel is Michael
von Falkenberg who is the Charles
Elliott professor of practice in
landscape architecture at the Graduate
School of Design here he's also the head
of michael von Falkenberg associates
which he founded in nineteen eighty-two
and
have he has designed and conceived of
over 350 projects everything from the
Brooklyn Bridge Park to the wellesley
college campus plan to the restoration
of Harvard Yard our first speaker for
the panel is my distinguished colleague
in the history of architecture at
Harvard in the history of art and
architecture department Professor Joseph
Connors who has previously served as the
director of the american academy in rome
and the villa i tatti it's hard to think
of a better person to address the topic
of Harvard's architecture please join me
in welcoming him to the podium the
origins of this talk are the wish to
incorporate the Harvard Yard the old
yard into the large introduction to
architecture course that I'll be taking
over next year twinning it with Central
Park I want the students to feel that
each time they walk through the arbors
they do dozens of times a day that they
are really seeing something new every
time my favorite quote is from bernard
berenson who after hundreds of times
walking up the same hillsides in Fiesole
would come back to his family and say
where were my eyes yesterday and I hope
that they will be saying that to to
someone who has spent 20 years teaching
at Columbia the ideal campus is designed
by a single mind or a very close set of
mines architect and patron focuses on a
great haghia sophia or pantheon is
enclosed from the outside world by a
fence is a built of the same materials
for every building with light variations
and is so symmetrical that the one
building that has been left out of the
master plan the symmetry for avery
library is still called on campus the
missing tooth when you come to Harvard
it's obviously totally different Harvard
you see here where for instance the
Smith Center now is outlined was a small
very small village the village of Newton
we know a lot about the early history of
Harvard thanks to the fact
that in the 300th anniversary the
so-called centennial an enormous amount
of scholarship was done on Massachusetts
and all the small towns on the campus
and the three-volume history of Harvard
was finally presented after many years
of work by Sam and Elliott Morrison to
the trustees who are a little shocked
that these three enormous volumes went
up to and included 1698 in any case it's
from this that we know I know so much
about the origins of the University it
began with a purchase of a house that
was four or five years old a pain
treehouse I encircle also the meeting
house which is the new meeting house
later in the 17th century but always
available except that Harvard didn't
chose not to use it the old ship church
in hingham gives us still a good idea of
what that meeting house looked like to
envisage where Harvard started you go to
the gate with the wonderful sadly well
the wonderful ode of Horus on it which
praises eternal marriage the last line
of his most misogynistic poem against
his mistress Lydia than any case it's a
beautiful line you see where the pain
treehouse was and its lot or a yard for
obviously farming and cattle grazing a
budding on the ox yard to the North
looked something like this the pain
treehouse was first used and then
Harvard Hall demolished 40 years later
was built on the back of the lot on the
back of the lot if you look closely at
the gate very nicely an inscription
commemorates the second house the Gulf
house or the Gulf college which occupied
a long similar lot on which the back of
which the Indian college was built so by
16 but 40 or so Harvard had four
buildings three of which were in wood
and one the Indian college not of course
used by Indians but by the press and
this is just to remind you of things on
the right the Wadsworth health of the
1740s is still there and you can get
some ideas I said of the of the meeting
house now old Harvard was reconstructed
in the 1930s by Morrison and short Levin
it's where all of the great events of
the early history of the University took
place this is their idea of a kind of
Tudor mansion
it's a time when Harvard was suffering
the great re migration of Puritans back
to Puritan England which they now found
sympathetic finally half of Harvard
graduates went back home before 1660 so
it's a time of lowering enrollments and
so forth nonetheless it was thought
fitting that a college be built for the
multitude of persons cohabiting for
scholastically communication whereby to
actuate the minds of one another so
living together and learning together as
the spirit however it was not big enough
and it was very rickety the area I've
outlined on the right faced backed on
the Ox pasture and looked over to the
cow common and of course is where the
famous three original buildings of
Harvard the so-called quad of Harvard
was built this wonderful burgess price
view of 1726 shows what he calls the
colleges because they're all called a
college harvard hauled number two or
Harvard College number two was on the
left and it's where many great events in
the history of the University took place
it's where John Harvard's library is
good for instance and there was a
philosophical chamber and a
philosophical cabinet I think which
we'll learn more about in any case the
quad something like the three-sided quad
something like Emmanuel College
Cambridge was built a counter clockwise
from the second Harvard Hall in 1670 a
time of war with the Indians but still
built to 20 years later a stotan call
number one which is not named for the
Israel Stoughton who was the perpetrator
of the genocide against the Pequots but
for William Stoughton who was the
hanging judge at Salem proving you could
count on the students to finally
Massachusetts Hall of 17 19 which is
always pointed out as the oldest
building at Harvard but it's salutary to
remember that it's the fifth building
built for Harvard and the seventh
building in which Harvard which Harvard
used it perpetrated lior it really
formed this idea that Harvard would be a
three-sided quadrangle looking out in a
very public way towards the common not
inwardly towards
we now think of as the yard and the
placement of these beautiful shell like
windows that were later later removed
but you can find them in Newport shown
on the print and of the clock facing
outward shows you some sense of the
public stance of Harvard this quad was
then duplicated on the north with the
building of Holden chapel in 1742 and
then in the 1760s of Halas Hall
providing another small three-sided
courtyard again looking out at the
common Holden Chapel is a favorite of
mine and I love to take students there
and say don't you realize you're in the
oldest really contained part of Harvard
that to your left is a building of 17 42
your right as a building of where John
Harvard's library still existed for 20
more years after that and most students
I know never even get to this little
hidden part of Harvard the strength of
Harvard's buildings was not in the
unified plan of Columbia but in the fact
that buildings were able to turn from
back to front what had been the back
would become the front and then as well
see there were two powerful buildings
which were from the beginning
double-sided the chapel of course faced
the common that's to say where the red
arrow is and that's where the original
facade was but it was turned around that
door was blocked is still blocked you
can't open that door and you eventually
get to the other facade a wonderful twin
but a false twin and it's the
connoisseurs well it's the students I
want to open their eyes that when you
look at one facade you have real Dora
capitals and you look at the other well
it's a back facade it's not really meant
to be complete but the line generated by
Holden will become a dominant line for
the rest of the Harvard Yard you notice
the pump back there it pumps and
latrines privies and pig sties and so
forth or all the marks of the back of
the building and this indeed was the
back of these two buildings and it's the
backs ability to turn into front which
is important for instance if you look at
the main door of Hollis West the door
facing the common it's a beautifully
elaborate corinthian door and you look
at the other side which we now think of
us the front of the building you
was how much simpler it is now here's
what happened to the original quad at
first harvard hole burned in 1764
destroying john harvard's library then
it was replaced relatively rapidly with
the building that's still there although
you hardly see it under all the
additions Harvard Hall three then the
Stoughton building was demolished was so
rickety it had been even affected by the
lisbon earthquake apparently which
reached harvard and somehow it was a
good thing because the walls were so
leaning than worth the earthquake
straighten the walls but nonetheless it
disappeared and then the idea finally
was to have no building at all but to
construct university hall one of the
most beautiful buildings Charles
Bulfinch had a fantastic idea of the
double facade of building this is the
west facade facing the common and the
almost identical East facade except it
had no granite staircases and was much
simpler and the privies and so forth
were all back there again bull finches
idea was marvelous to surround it with a
group of trees to make it really the
center of the new college some randomly
placed buildings began to move on let's
say migrate East Gore Hall the library
was said in a picturesque landscape like
Andrew Jackson downing or that sort of
thing the wonderful print here was used
on the plaque that's now on wired in the
library right down to the top hats of
the little figures and since the
building was the newest building in
Cambridgeshire at Harvard when Cambridge
was incorporated as a city in 1846 it's
become the symbol of the city of
Cambridge and it's on the seal wherever
you find out as you know it faced
massachusetts avenue and the temptation
was always to have a library facing
massachusetts avenue the gate built by
the class of nineteen seventy-seven
which means either in 1902 or 1907 25 or
30 years later is the gate of misplaced
expectations because it was in 1909 that
the corporation decided that the new
library whatever it was would not face
Massachusetts Avenue but would make a
theater so to speak facing the inside of
the yard the other building somewhat
randomly played well not quite randomly
plays does the Gothic Chapel
18 56 of course demolish now for
memorial church but put right on line of
Holden chapel in that line going through
Appleton Chapel would eventually give
the line of Robinson Hall which would
make the final quadrangle on the eastern
side now how to expand into the east if
you took the original quadrangle the
yellow line show it would have been too
small if you took a university hall and
made a twin it also would have been too
small there was a kind of wandering and
finally what's happening is that the
much larger axis of Holden chapel and
mass wall will determine the quadrangle
on the east first comes Richardson and
Richardson's massive wonderful Seaver
Hall of 18 late 70s and 1880 will
determine the rest of the building in
the campus it's a wonderful two sided
building as you can see with slight
differences for instance the beautiful
arched door facing the yard is very
different from the classical door facing
what's now the fog museum but otherwise
it's double sided and from the office of
Richardson we have an amazing plan that
shows that three not only would we have
had Seaver but three other turreted
castles in the Romanesque style would
have made the boundary of the campus on
Quincy Street it would have been the
best largest assembly of Richardson
buildings in Massachusetts rivaling the
famous set of Richardson's five richards
and buildings in northeastern mass but
it didn't happen thanks to the arrival
of Charles fallen McKim who built the
fence which is really what gives the
yard its definition and is a wonderful
thing to look at we seldom do but we
pass through it many times every day and
part of my goal is to get the students
well for instance to see that it was
given by many classes all of whom were
enlisted and the way you get the date of
the front fence of that portion of the
fences you add either 25 or 30 depending
on when the Alumni Association hit that
class up so a 70 will give you a fence
of 95 or 1900 and so on
gates of course were paid for by not by
alumni classes the mckean gate opposite
the Porcellian Club is wonderful for
lovers of Florence because it brings the
fantastic mannerist partially know the
origin of porcelian on to Harvard's into
Harvard sculptural repertoire the
biggest and best is the Johnston gate 12
huge piers paid for by mr. Johnston of
Chicago but the best place if you look
on the left and the right you'll see
these inscriptions here and here best
place to learn about the history of
Harvard as I hope students will that it
was founded by the general best to learn
the facts but then to remember the
omissions founded by the General Court
1636 it doesn't say it was supposed to
be in salem then ordered to be at Newton
well Wyatt Newton while because Anne
Hutchinson was creating so much trouble
in Boston that you could preach without
going to the new University they said
let's not put it in Boston either we'll
put it Newton so it was changed to
Cambridge and then finally changed to
Harvard College as you know and on the
other side this wonderful text New
England's first fruits is the missionary
pamphlet sent back to the Society for
the propagation of the faith in the
gospel in New England sent back to
England because they were generous with
the idea that Indians or Native
Americans would be educated in this
College the Johnson gate has another
thing that often slips below the
threshold of our consciousness namely
bad brick making in the colonial era
often burned the bricks and that was
imitated by McKim in a marvelous way
which is now called Harvard brick go to
Widener and so forth you can find it
other things that the fence do that we
forget is it gave water to students and
of course to passing horses which were
still going on kirkland Street in the
first decade of the century such as this
lovely fountain of nineteen seven on the
left and this fountain the lion fountain
just opposite the fire house with a huge
trough in a big Exedra and I often asked
myself what is this Exedra doing with
the two openings not in the center but
either and then I said well let's take
away Canaday see what happens there's
the old fog
the right and this Exedra on the left
and this candidate blocking everything
in a very insensitive 1970s way but if
you look at where those lines of sight
went one went to the tower of the old
chapel still there at nineteen seven and
the other one on the left the one that
goes straight goes all the way across
campus and winds up under the later
wigglesworth and winds up with this
wonderful Dexter gate where if you go
into the dexter gate you say enter to
grow in wisdom and if you leave the
dexter gate you say depart to serve
better thy country and I kind all of
this was connected visually right across
campus now blocked by planting and by
PUC and by of course the terrible
Canaday back to the Richardson
quadrangle on the left you had emerson
hall built around 1900 but the money for
emerson came not from those philosophers
who are so proudly trumpeted in the
inscription but from something called
the department of social not social faux
what is it social ethics which was
highly endowed in fact it brought in the
money francis greenwald Peabody's
friendly donors brought in the money not
only for the building but for something
called the social museum in emerson hall
and this is what that was like a study
which we would now think of as something
like social work or social ethics
beautifully a catalogue recently in an
exhibit in the fog museum and on the
right Robinson Hall which all of our
history students we've just heard about
this go in thinking its history until
they look up and say its architecture
built by H Langford Warren and my hobby
at the moment is to find the sources of
all of these wonderful reliefs on the
idea that every learn in person at the
time would have said these are all
pretty obvious they're part of her the
baggage of culture that we all carry
with us like this famous sarcophagus now
on the Vatican or the wonderful
inscriptions all from Pompeii when you
think of the McKim firm trying to do
inscriptions in any case what happened
to this enterprise the showing you some
of the things
epistemological three epistemological
changes exiled all of the collecting
that was going on at this end of the
campus in the old fog museum the idea
was no longer casts it was full of casts
and the wave of casts swept through
America in the 1890s but the real thing
how many of those statues are real only
the warrant or so which is now in the
fog museum and the idea was authentic
art not cast will be the teaching of the
future which was the philosophy of the
new fog the social museum was swept away
by the introduction of scientific
sociology which resented as a department
the presence of social ethics and
gradually exiled the museum and absorbed
it into itself in the 1930s and finally
just as the Smolny convent in st.
Petersburg was the place where Lenin
hatched the Bolshevik Revolution so to
Robinson Hall was the place where the
course of architecture in education in
america and in building would be changed
drastically as the new dean hudnut
arrived sweeping away all those casts
hiring gropius and introducing an
entirely different philosophy of
education the east end of the camp is so
full of collections after the 1930s
would have no collections anymore
it's very dangerous to invite people
like Joseph Connors and myself to give
talks on topics that we would actually
like three days to take up so I gave a
good bit of thought to how I would talk
about the trees of Harvard Yard and
decided to largely tell it from the
position of first person singular as I
realized in preparing this in a way that
I hadn't before that slowly up until
nineteen up up until 2007 when president
faust looked at me and said oh I
understand you're the curator of the
landscape of Harvard Yard I realized
sort of over a 25-year period I had kind
of unwittingly taking taken on a
responsibility of thinking of all of
this Joe asked me where we got the
colored picture that he was showing in
black and white and I told them on the
internet I don't think he found that a
very suitable answer but my young
assistant found this image to start with
and one of the questions that I wanted
to think about relative to collecting is
the new things that are living like
landscape is the nature of the entity
that collects them and the frame that
they're collected in and and and why
they were collected and I think Joe did
a wonderful job of actually showing me
things about the yard I had never seen
but I can't help but think about the
significance of the early we one
presumes that there is some accuracy
although one never knows with these
engravers because they took great
Liberty on landscape there probably
was a tree there and it probably was an
elm but it is the beginning of a very
huge problem for Harvard that happens
with the arrival of the Dutch elm
disease and the fact that the yard which
I'm going to explain in a minute was
almost a monoculture of trees that were
destined to either go into decline or
die or at least to be trees that would
not significantly ever be replanted
because of the inability of this species
to survive with the disease that we have
the yard as a as a place where trees
have been collected in the contemporary
sense is largely three spaces on the old
yard the tercentenary and the Seaver and
this is roughly what Harvard looked like
in the middle of the 20th century and
you can find no fault with the original
formers of Harvard Yard thinking that
American elm would be a beautiful tree
to have in the yard it was fast growing
strong easy to transplant widely
available long-lived and magnificent but
it also has a natural habit that would
come to define a quality that the yard
has which is the self leming of the
lower branches so that over time you get
this very unique quality of a very high
canopy and columns of the tree coming
down into the space which is going to
become one of my problems in the early
90s when we decided to replant those Joe
also talked about I love now
understanding how why I'm confused when
I look at the history of the campus that
certain halls seem to be in different
locations they would build one tear it
down build another one in a new location
and just use the same name someplace
else
but the John Harvard statue was for a
very long time by Memorial Church and
moved into the yard right at this sort
of heyday of the period of American elms
i actually discovered this photograph
while staying at the faculty club in new
york city or the harvard club it's not
the faculty club but as an assistant
professor but there was a period in time
where harvard actually moved in a new
almost an entire replanting of the
American elm population that is in that
this by the way I think you can tell
rather unusual size to be moving trees
so just to give you a glimpse of the
importance of trees in the early history
of the yard in the imeem in the recent
early history so some dispute on the
internet and I'm no expert as to when
Dutch elm arrived Cornell says 1930
other sources say 1950 but by and it was
in Buffalo New York and so very quickly
that disease spread in all directions
and eventually resulted in many trees
being lost so I have actually worked on
collecting trees in the yard for 44
different presidents and twice for Derek
Bok when after president summers left
there was a period of time where where
he was acting president my own i arrived
in 82 and 89 peter del tredici and i
were asked by the President to be on a
committee to anticipate the replanting
of the yard it was sort of a kind of
thing that you did as a young professor
I mean I mean for what among other
things that when the president asks you
to do things before your tenured you do
and if you're nice you continue to do it
after your tenured but then when Neil
Rudin Stein arrived from the lush
Princeton campus he hired my firm to do
a master plan to radically re-landscape
in the vegetative sense the yard and we
produced a master plan for the
replanting of 250 trees in the first
five years of the 90s under under the
time when Neil was here and that was in
this 1993 master plan I'm going to jump
ahead a little bitter we're going to run
out of time so it's hard to remember for
those of you that were not here that by
the early 90s the old yard was almost
half empty of trees that elm trees were
being removed and there was a total deer
in the headlights quality among
everybody of knowing that the Elms
couldn't be replaced but what would be
done and so we started doing an
inventory for instance here you can see
how few trees that were in the space
that I call the Seaver quad which I
think of as being completed across
quincy street by the fog by the way and
then how we would propose to replant
that for instance another thing that i
did it was a willful act which is i
think actually something very common to
collectors which is that they get to
exercise things that they have developed
their own beliefs about but I or we my
office and I chose to commemorate the
entrances to the yard all the way around
by pairing trees that restated the point
of entry and that was something that I
had seen in the remnants of the Olmstead
brothers replanting of the yard done
elsewhere there wasn't really any more
legitimacy beyond that than I
seen its value but also there seemed to
be this interesting palimpsest of
entries which had existed and which had
been closed in which I wanted to draw
new attention to by pairing trees at the
entry so this is actually a male and
female Kentucky coffee tree right after
it was planted in 93 and this is matt
moffatts photograph that he took just a
day ago of seeing how that pair of trees
is growing so you know as a person who
was teaching plants at the time through
the early 90s to the Graduate School of
Design and with a decision that we were
not going to replace the trees in the
yard with another monoculture Dan Kiley
Raider later wrote to me after we did it
and his letter was dear Michael you have
ruined Harvard Yard Dan but for instance
for those of you that know Smith were
they elected to do it with zelkova and
an Illinois where it was done with honey
locust there have been similar not at
Smith but at Illinois similar
consequential losses of monocultures and
so we made a decision partly as a
collection for students to study but
also as a way of creating something more
ecologically sustainable to plant
replant the yard with 30 species to in
certain spaces such as at the at the end
of Seaver and Robinson we chose to
introduce plants that were actually in
some ways I'll be kind and say unusual
to the yard which was to introduce a
planting of four meta sequoias but
recognizing Harvard's presence in in
contemporary horticultural history of
introducing that tree from China and
then another thing that happened was the
Cambridge Historical Commission
wanted us to commemorate the fact that
the privies in the yard had been planted
in charl sullivan sense with pines to
screen them and then allowed to grow up
and he wanted that kind of homage to the
primordial forest but also to that very
pragmatic and quirky bit of history of
pines being in the yard for screening
and then being allowed to grow up so
those were replanted so I'm a little bit
over my time how much longer do you not
want me to talk two minutes okay my
drawing actually of the tercentenary but
explaining one of the one of the central
ideas which was that the middle of the
space would have trees with lighter
foliage and bring the sense of
brightness and definition of the center
so we did use honey locust with it's
sort of dappled light and then a
stronger reiteration of the perimeter
with geometry and a number of red maples
and then which is very funny the
planting of yellow woods to coincide
with graduation around the first week in
May when it no longer happens and so the
yellow woods live on beautifully and I
lovingly remember back in the day when
they bloom during graduation and it's
just another one of those marks in
history that's a I guess another aspect
of collecting which is that decisions
are made for one reason and then that
changes so that's what the trees look
like on the top after we planted them
and then on the bottom the yellow woods
have done extremely well and filled in
we were very barren of trees by the
early 90s
and then the replanting of those and
then I guess I'll just make one other
point and then run through the slides
what we observed had been done
historically was that when trees that
were not Elms were introduced into the
yard arborists and I suppose maybe
landscape architects had made the
decision to remove the lower branches
and the identity of trees is very much
through their form among obviously their
leaves and other things and so this is
actually a recent photograph you can see
one of my white pines in the distant
planet and growing up you can see
American elms and red oaks looking very
similar because the lower branches have
been removed from the red oaks to make
them more like Elms which is what the
tree on the right is because there still
are many Elms in the yard but as a
strategy we have taken the collection
which has ecological diversity and
working with amazing people who run the
grounds department and slowly are
removing branches so that that vaulted
and lifted feeling that the Elms had as
a monoculture or nearly as a monoculture
is today complemented with the others
I'll just go through these so that
you've seen them I wanted to end on I
think one of the really major changes
when drew became president I told her I
I told her I hoped I could walk around
whether that summer one thing settled
down and explained what we've been doing
in the yard and she turned to me and
said you know if if I could grant you
one wish that isn't exactly what she
said but it was kind of what she said if
I could do one thing for you what would
it be and I would and I said I think it
would be great to bring in this guy T
Fleischer who is working on how
biologically to reinvigorate the soil
and the grass of the yard but that in so
doing by changing the chemistry and the
by all
g of the soil I think we would lengthen
the likelihood of the of the trees as a
collection sustaining longer and she did
that she just and it was a switch that
was actually ready to be thrown in the
politics of the university but we have
one of the greenest campuses in America
because of of that decision that drew
made so anyway thank you
next Monday there's going to be an
unveiling of my most recent portrait
commissioned by the harbor foundation
the portrait honors contributions of
accomplishments of the United States
treasurer Rosa Rios a 1987 graduate of
Winthrop house where the portrait will
hang Rios has led a distinguished career
in regional economic development and
wild Harvard she played a critical role
in the creation of the Harvard
foundation which is dedicated to
improving cultural diversity relations
at Harvard her senior thesis was on
changing notions of Latino identity to
my knowledge of about 700 painted
portraits at Harvard her portrait will
be the first of a Latino and certainly
the first of a Latina woman I show you
the portrait but it's an unveiling and I
can't the setting of the portrait is her
Treasury office facing the White House
with the treasures flag of 1789 hang
beside her and behind miss Rios is the
desk given to American treasurer by the
country flank France in colonial times
and near to portrait she looks out at
the viewer with confidence but
approachability and encouragement to the
students that it will walk by the
portrait in winthrop house it does look
different from most portraits at Harvard
and it is supposed to it's supposed to
get attention and have something to say
the unveiling be a great event members
of family will be there probably some
people from Washington as well and
members of Harvard's Latino Student
Alliance will play a major role thrilled
that a member of their community will
finally find a place on Harvard's walls
at unveilings tears flow and emotions
run high but I also know that this event
is just the beginning of the life cycle
of a portrait at Harvard portraits last
much longer than people's memories
portraits last longer than rooms in most
Harvard buildings and even longer than
most Harvard buildings as you've heard
this creates an obvious problem
because we're portrait is hung at a
university is often an integral part of
the portrait itself spatial associations
are almost always a vivid component of
any unveiling moving portraits around
which universities must do for any
number of reasons breaks those
associations this is belinda randall
eighteen sixteen to eighteen ninety
seven she was part of an important
family in stowe massachusetts she and
her brother were acquainted with Emerson
Thoreau and Margaret Fuller and she was
an early subscriber to Fuller's
conversations just before her death miss
Randall bequeathed to Harvard funds to
create a badly needed new dining hall
for students at the college this is
randell hall it was construct the corner
of divinity ave in kirkland Street and
it served as a dynamo for about twenty
years after which it became the home of
Harvard University Press and in 1930 the
store family gave this portrait of the
lynda randle painted in 1842 harvard to
hang in Randall Hall however in 1963
Randall Hall was demolished and it's now
where William James always the portrait
of Belinda Randall was moved to the
faculty club but when the faculty club
was renovated the interior decorator in
charge was heard to common and decry the
seemingly random portraits on the walls
she described them as shabby chic and
the portrait of Miss Randall was sent to
storage the likely final stop for this
portrait in its life as a university
portrait if Randall's portraitists had
become famous however the outcome might
have been different John Singer Sargent
was in Boston working on the Boston
Public Library murals when he received a
commission to paint a portrait of a
Civil War veteran who had donated money
so that Harvard could create a new
dining hall also new dining hall but
this one would be specifically for poor
students the new dining hall became the
Harvard Union where I ate as a freshman
and the veteran was Henry Lee higgenson
it was grateful Harvard students who
commissioned sergeant to create the
portrait he consents imposing portrait
hung in the Union for many years and
survived extensive remodeling recently
though it was moved to the recently
reopened Harvard art museum the work by
sergeant had become enormously important
piece of heart art history and become
extremely valuable and such works in
public areas are vulnerable to
accidental damage and worse but moving
it change the story in its new home the
portrait is not about the remarkable
generosity repaid by grateful students
it is now about the skill of the
portraitist and the emotion associated
with the Civil War blanket resting in
higgenson slab moving portraits is
common and stories change accordingly
Harvard commissioned John Singleton
Copley in the 1770s create three
portraits of Thomas Hollis Thomas
Hancock and Nicholas boylston however
with the remodeling of Harvard hall
there was no space for such large works
much less for three large works all hung
together and by the way the three were
supposed to hang in Harvard hall to
recognize the donate the donation of
three professorships among I think it's
the first three professor jobs at
Harvard well a Harvard hall when it was
remodeled couldn't handle it and the car
frames had become too fragile and
delicate and so the three were relocated
to new locations around the campus
Hollis and Hancock went to a Harvard
house dining room boylston to the count
way library at harvard medical school
where they are right now i cannot say a
wonderful portrait of nicholas boylston
on the end does hang in the Harvard art
museum newly reopened and it's a
wonderful painting but it is not the one
commissioned by Harvard foreign dowling
professorship the message of Harvard's
gratitude for financial support
has been lost at least for now the
portrait you see in the museum is an
earlier portrait of boylston that Copley
used while creating the harvard
commission portrait because by then
boylston had died so you can see it's
the same image and Copley did his own
version of Photoshop to create the later
portrait my fervent hope is the Harvard
art museum someday reunites the three
and retells again the reason for their
existence at Harvard I think we owe that
to the three generous donors a few years
ago I had personal involvement in
relocating a portrait at Harvard the
Harvard foundation commissioned me to
create a posthumous portrait of
Professor anna-marie Schimmel a
distinguished Islamic scholar and poet
professor Sean was a prolific scholar
teacher and she wrote more than 100
books during her scholarly career 100
books and monographs professor Schimmel
spent many years living in Elliott house
and the master of Elliott house thought
it was a natural place for her portrait
to hang the the students were extremely
eager the Islamic community with the
idea of having a portrait go up in la
house one that included in fact I put
Arabic calligraphy in the background
readable by students who knew Arabic and
it studying the problem was there's no
room on the walls in the Elliott house
library and the decision was made to
replace the only portrait of a non
housemaster a portrait of Professor
Walter Jackson bait whose humanities
course I took and loved at Harvard he
died in 1999 professor bait was the
winner of two full of surprises an
outstanding scholar and teacher my
portrait of outstanding scholar anamarie
symbol now hangs in the spot occupied by
outstanding scholar Walter Jackson bait
this was just a no-win situation
University simply do not have
room to honor all those who deserve to
be honored and by a wide margin this is
the fundamental relentless heartbreak of
university portraits and the heartbreak
gets worse as walls become glass
ceilings become lower security for it
becomes more problematic and expensive
and renovators for shabby chic
portraiture for Mentalist
low-maintenance renovated university
walls professor Schimmel's portrait now
hangs in LA and house library to prepare
for today's session I went looking for
an image of professor Bates portrait so
I could show it to you one might hope
that the scarcity of space on University
walls might be remedied by seemingly
infinite space to display University
portraits with their full story on the
web here's what I found there are no
good images of professor Bates portrait
anywhere that i could find anywhere on
the web i couldn't find it at the
harvard art museum site i couldn't find
it at the artist site know where i find
this disturbing I was not expecting to
discover this further ignem a of an end
of cycle status for a university
portrait an online memorial consisting
only of a low resolution black-and-white
portrait a black-and-white photographs I
don't mean to say that there aren't
portraits fortune of portraits that are
well documented and inspire and instruct
us in great places such as the faculty
rum and turns out the department of
astronomy in the philosophy department I
I think this is maybe because the strom
need to write and ever move because of a
telescope and I don't think the
philosophy department move because you
don't move philosophers these fortunate
portraits have escaped another
unfortunate end to a university portrait
and a one I would call anonymity I visit
Harvard buildings in Harvard houses
often quite often I'm deeply saddened
when I see portraits that have no
no attribution no description of why
portrait was commissioned or hung this
is because these portraits are refugees
of Harvard buildings that have been
repurposed or they result of unveilings
that were never quite completed with
proper labeling a very common problem
and now a bit worse since I Harvard Art
Museum eliminated the position a
portrait curator when the fog was closed
for renovation unlabeled portraits say
little to students other than suggesting
that Harvard has a history and unlabeled
portraits encourage and condone ignoring
University portraits altogether I find
this a troubling message to give
students about the value of history and
learning not to mention respect for the
contributions of others facing the fact
that University poor efforts must
confront a challenging life cycle is not
all that dissimilar to what we face in
life itself I mean we all know that in
life we come we live and then most of us
are forgotten so apparently too with
portraits but the high irony here is
that the whole idea of portraits was
that they were supposed to change that
in the face of this as a portraitist I
still try to fight back to defy that
life cycle I try to make white portraits
interesting I try to tell my subject
story how they contributed to Harvard
and to humanity humanity as a whole as
clearly as I can I just want to make
these University artifacts like the
portrait of Rosa Rios worth keeping
around thank
well thank you i I don't I trying to
recall if I've ever been able to say of
a panel I've been involved in that it
was a kind of campus altering experience
to do to hear and witness but I think
that's the case for this panel I am I
wanted to thank our speakers and I just
had one very brief question that I
thought we'd start off the discussion
with to maybe tie them together which is
that all of you in your own ways have
thought about different perspectives on
the way the campus is oriented the way
sight lines and the experience of the
campus are conditioned through axes of
passage and entry and so forth but
taking the spirit of Stephen quoits
presentation and asking our other two
presenters from their perspectives to
comment on whether there are objects
such as portraits other kinds of objects
which aren't necessarily usually
associated with a built environment or
with an urbanistic function which do
play an urban istic role in orienting or
conditioning our experience of the
campus that aren't necessarily
infrastructure buildings or the yard
would any of you care to comment on this
all I can say is I for this talk and
before I've been trying to find
portraits of buildings and it's a
wonderful custom at Harvard when you
tear down a building to put a plaque on
it which has a portrait of the previous
building and so gore hall or Appleton
Chapel are both represented on their
successors and I hope this is continued
as a custom I'm not sure this is
answering the question but in two years
Winthrop house is going to be remodeled
and it's that I think it's the third
house that's a fourth house that will be
remodeled and I don't think that
portraits and where they will hang have
ever figured in a remodeling and to
consciously not leave room for history
seems to be doesn't sit well with me
well that's what's interesting about the
unplanned campus at Harvard right it's
perpetually in turmoil and change and
replanting and master plans don't have a
very long life but every time something
changes it has these invisible ripple
effects with other kinds of objects
which get dispersed in ways that we
haven't fully perhaps appreciated well
in the spirit of that I wanted to kind
of open the floor to two questions from
the audience we have a Q&A we have a mic
set up in the central aisle so we ask
you to just identify yourself and your
affiliation when you ask your question
thank you please thank you hi oh great
um hi I'm Abigail while I'm a graduate
student in the Slovak department thank
you all so much for three fascinating
presentations I want to propose an
answer to your question there's a
collection of bike racks around the
University they're all very different
some of them are more useful than others
because of their design but also because
of where they're located next to the
building the ones I've said the Science
Center are spacious and inviting but
there's little ones tucked away next to
lamont which open out onto a street that
you can't ride your bike down so
something to keep in mind i have a
question for professor Connors I wonder
if you could
comment on the history and the eclectic
style of Memorial Church Memorial Chapel
is that what it's called Chapel Church
it's called it's pretty big so I don't
know think of it as a chapel but also um
I was very struck by what you said about
how the earlier planning of Harvard took
into account the relationships between
the different buildings sight lines and
I wonder if you can comment on the
extent to which say the brutalist
Science Center interacts with Memorial
Church well just a few things the church
is a brilliant building in a way the
students I say picture the parson on and
then picture the spire of Old South
Church and put the ladder on the former
and they say you're crazy that's exactly
what's happening in Memorial Church and
it gives the university a center seen
from miles away it's brilliant in that
sense that the two porches one creating
the theater and one the real entrance is
also brilliant the memorial the war war
one memorial inside the North would be
no the South the main and the main porch
must be an amazing structure because
that huge bell tower is right over the
open space must be an incredible trust
of steel in there so all sorts of
wonderful things are going on and I
really love that building actually it's
on the same line a little holden chapel
determines where it is that little
chapel determined and there was a direct
link visual link between the old
appleton chapel and holden chapel until
terrible brutal really ugly and
unpleasant ther was built in eighteen
sixty nine and that blocked the idea of
that visual link the gates i spoke about
the gates and one of those gates so i
have a picture i didn't show but you
take it from near the chapel and it
looks out at what looks like a
tremendous tarantula coming in your
direction and i learned that the just
yesterday that the after memorial hall
was
burnt in the 1950s and the tower burnt
there was something of a policy of let
it rot so that it would someday be seen
just about right to pull this terribly
ugly Victorian monster down and a new
scion of the science building or
something like that would have been
built there so that didn't happen and
you can see how buildings outlive their
tastes and rutin Stein's repairing or
restoring of the tower Memorial Hall as
kind of a sea change in the reevaluation
of a building I see a fellow faculty
director of the Radcliffe Institute it's
Janet rich Edwards i'm here at Radcliffe
and also Harvard Medical School and my
question is for professor coit the
biggest collection artistically ah there
you go the biggest collection of
portraits of which I'm aware are in the
bornstein auditorium at brigham and
women's hospital right and it's a
fabulous very rich collection of
portraits but like many female faculty
members we feel oppressed by the fact
that I think only one out of there must
be 50 is a woman and so my question for
you is you get this almost Malthusian
problem of you know all these portraits
and no space how do you think about
making room for new and more diverse
generations while preserving the history
fortunately most of the time it's not my
problem and in fact my as the artist for
the harbor foundation we are to bring a
diversity to the walls of our tree that
better reflects students and the faculty
they they see every day and so we've
done people of color Asians women Sri
Lankans Japanese to bring that diversity
the the problem of where you hang them
is is the big problem and I say with
only a little small glibness that any of
you could commissioned a portrait at
Harvard that's easy what's really hard
is finding the place to put it and that
is a
decision that is fraught with
disagreements about who owns space and
I'm sure in that in that space you would
find several entities that believe they
command the decision of what portrait
goes where and and interests will be
protected it's it's a serious problem
and and actually one I would welcome
some some better clarity on because the
choice of what portraits you put up is
is a little like some of the library
decisions we heard in the earlier panel
um how do you make these decisions to
preserve learning to record history and
and given that that shelf space wall
space is limited how do you do that and
it's a deeply it's a deep Pedego logical
decision that should be made not through
infighting but by thinking about it I
never like to seriously hear anyone feel
oppressed but i do want to reflect that
the absence of women in those portraits
is an important reflection of history
and a bad one and we should be careful
not to forget that women have not
perhaps had the place even still in this
university that they deserve i teach in
a department that has only tenured two
women in its 110 year history which is
shocking in a field where women have
played as important a role in landscape
architecture as they have and seventy
percent of our students today or female
but your comment makes me remember how
important collections are in terms of
what they sometimes inadvertently
reflect
well I just wanted to say I was once in
an analogous situation to Stevens where
as director of the american academy in
rome i was ex officio on the board of
something called the prop we call
erroneously the protestant cemetery
really it's the non catholic cemetery
because you can have orthodox you can
have atheists and so on in it but the
not in Catholic seminary cemetery and
being in use and people wanting to be
buried there but it's a limited plot of
land our committee was called the tenure
committee and if you are John Keats or
if you were Graham she you you got
tenure but if you had that wonderful
weeping cherub you might get tenure too
otherwise people had to depart all right
we have time for one final question
please go ahead my name is Concha Gandhi
I'm from Harvard University harbor area
which is the largest number of specimens
more than 5.4 million specimens but as
one of the farmer being said that's the
largest one arm of any collections on
campus anyway my question is about the
hard work yard trees you know the maples
and works are common anywhere and
everywhere I was I would have been
always curious about this Kentucky
coffee plant why that plant was chosen
because it's quite uncommon any
particular reason it was planted there
because I thought plants at Harvard and
I wanted a place where my students could
go and see it it's a absolutely as naive
as what I said which was I mean
truthfully at the time it's a tree
that's used extensively in my practice
but it's a tree that with age has a
structure naturally that's not unlike
the American elm so besides my desire
for it to be there so I could walk up to
it with my students in point it it is
considered by some as a significant tree
that had been under
appreciate it in its history perhaps I
gave it to promenade a location i don't
know i like you to join me in thanking
our three speakers for this wonderful
panel thank you very much
you